[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8 politique
sur tv et 78 nous sommes le 19 janvier
voici le sommaire la ministre déléguée
chargée de la ville mahdia et en
déplacement à poissy un déplacement pour
mettre en avant le label cité éducative
mais aussi faire le bilan de la lutte
contre la délinquance et la
radicalisation
les députés du modem des yvelines jean
noël barrot est dorénavant en charge de
l'identification des territoires
fragiles pour permettre leur rebond
économique les détails de sa mission
dans un instant avec lui et puis à
thomas gourland nouveau président de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
dévoile sa feuille de route pour ce
mandat
aménagement développement économique
mobilité tour d'horizon à suivre
[Musique]
la ministre nadia était donc dans les
yvelines mi janvier afin de promouvoir
le label cité éducative pour lequel le
gouvernement a décidé de débloquer
quelques 17 millions d'euros
son objectif permettre l'accompagnement
individuel de chaque enfant de la petite
enfance à l'insertion professionnelle la
ville de poissy a décidé de solliciter
cette aide célia garçons go et patrick
jacques de dixmude pour ce reportage
poissy pourrait faire partie des futurs
cité éducative
un programme qui vise à impliquer
l'intégralité des acteurs locaux dans
l'accompagnement éducatif des enfants
la ministre de la ville nadia est était
en visite dans la commune yvelinoise
pour étudier le projet les acteurs se
mettent ensemble se mettent autour d'une
table et réfléchissent à une méthode de
travail a aussi les divers
accompagnements que qui peuvent
mutualiser proposé pour servir le
parcours de l'enfant dans le cadre de sa
réussite scolaire
aujourd'hui déjà 80 cité éducative ont
été labellisés en france ce qui
représente 520 mille enfants accompagnés
les 12 17 ans doivent être les premiers
bénéficiaires de ce programme l'école le
sport la culture les parents avec 7
cette épine dorsale que pour présenter
du cassiot nationale peut être pour nous
un élément facilitateur qui n'a d'autre
objectif que de bien vivre ensemble
outre l'éducation nationale le but est
d'aider des initiatives locales déjà
existantes comme ici à la fabrique
numérique du fab lab qui a un objectif
simple qui est de former des jeunes donc
17 29 ans qui sont en échec scolaire
souvent déscolarisés qui n'ont pas le
bac voilà pour essayer de susciter a une
vocation ou de les aider avec les outils
qu'on a sur place une formation plus
poussée ou un emploi dernier axe du
projet cité éducative la sécurité un
comité de prévention de la délinquance
s'est tenue dans la journée autour de la
table les acteurs locaux ont présenté
leurs idées pour lutter contre la
délinquance en travaillant avec les
associations travaillant avec les
services de police
les collectivités la collectivité locale
et ses élus l'éducation nationale et
donc ses commandes tout le monde se
mobilise pour lutter efficacement contre
la délinquance
si poissy 20 et à bénéficier de cette
aide la ville toucherait 450000 euros de
l'état pour la mise en place de ce
projet nous allons continuer à évoquer
la sortie de crise avec jean-noël barrot
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député des
yvelines vous venez de recevoir une
mission de la part du gouvernement
identifier les territoires fragiles ce
qu'il ne faudra pas oublier pour que la
reprise économique soit un succès est-ce
que déjà aujourd'hui on mesure un peu
l'impact que va avoir cette crise
beaucoup d'entreprises vivent sous
perfusion grâce aux aides de l'état de
la région est néanmoins on peut déjà
avoir un peu une idée précise de
l'ampleur de la situation
ça fait partie de la mission qui nous
est confiée c'est à dire d'essayer
d'anticiper les territoires les zones
d'emploi les bassins de vie qui dans
quelques mois auront plus de difficultés
que d'autres à se relever et à rebondir
du fait de la violence du choc qu'ils
auront subi en dépit des des aides
massives qui ont été mises en place
depuis le mois de mars de l'année
dernière et d'une fragilité
préexistantes
il ya dans notre pays un certain nombre
de fractures taille et la crainte que
nous partageons tous c'est que le colis
ne viennent les amplifier vous êtes à
l'oeuvre depuis un peu plus d'une
semaine vous avez déjà identifié des
territoires plus en difficulté que
d'autres alors c'est une très bonne
question nous avons commencé à essayer
de le faire grâce à aux données qui
remontent dans les ministères sur la
situation économique des territoires
mais nous allons croiser ce ce
diagnostic sur la base de statistiques
si je puis dire avec une avec une vision
qui est celle
des élus des responsables économiques
locaux partout sur territoire avec une
attention particulière portée aux
territoires dont nous savons déjà à quel
point ils sont fragiles ou à quel point
ils sont violemment percutés par par la
colline ces territoires plus qu'ils sont
plus en difficulté plus fragiles et ce
qu'ils ont des points communs des signes
distinctifs peut-être on parle de zone
clusaz urbaine plus rurales plus mixte
avec certains types de population il ya
des signes distinctifs déjà écouté à ce
stade ce que l'on peut dire c'est que il
ya une grande diversité
évidemment qui dépend du tissu
industriel donc on pense aux
départements ou territoires qui sont
très fortement exposé à l'industrie
aéronautique et je pense en particulier
aux yvelines et et à l'industrie
automobile
et puis il ya évidemment toutes les
zones qui dépendent très largement du
tourisme et en particulier zone de
montagne mais pas uniquement les zones
côtières également ce qui est important
pour nous c'est qu'on puisse
effectivement croire et ses intuitions
avec les les difficultés de certains de
ses territoires
les difficultés préexistantes et de
france en particulier à la région de
toulouse toulouse qui est très fortement
spécialisés sur l'industrie aéronautique
et qui est aussi un territoire qui est
particulièrement fragile avec un taux de
chômage qui était particulièrement élevé
avant même l'entrée dans la crise de
kovy donc ce sens ce territoire qui vont
cumuler les difficultés auxquelles nous
allons accorder toute notre attention
alors vous allez accorder plus d'intérêt
en tout cas vous allez intervenir auprès
de ces territoires un petit peu plus
pour les aider sur le rebond une fois la
sortie de crise
engagé il s'agit pas forcément d'une
aide financière il ya eu beaucoup d'être
financière depuis bien tenant presque un
an
là le but c'est pas forcément de mettre
encore de l'argent sur la table
oui c'est très juste il y à il ya des
enveloppes très importantes qui ont été
libérés pour les mesures de soutien que
que chacun connaît désormais le fonds de
solidarité l'activité partielle les
reports de charges les prêts garantis
par l'état
et puis il ya cette enveloppe de 100
milliards d'euros l'enveloppent france
relance qui a vocation à engager notre
tissu économique dans une transition
industrielles porteuses
à venir donc il n'est pas exclu que nous
puissions recommander certains
ajustements au sein de cette enveloppe
d'aidé 100 milliards d'euros mais ce que
nous allons aussi regarder c'est s'il
subsiste un certain nombre d'obstacles à
ce que les entreprises puissent se
reconvertir les salariés puissent se
former correctement ou que tout
simplement il puisse y avoir de nouvelle
implantation de nouvelles entreprises
qui émergent
parce que c'est ça qui va nous permettre
de rebondir et compris dans les
territoires les plus est pour lui le
qu'on comprenne bien le sens de votre
mission aussi l'idée n'est pas forcément
uniquement d'accompagner les entreprises
de les aider si elles sont difficulté
c'est aussi d'aider les salariés et de
s'intéresser à l'ensemble de la
population
oui évidemment ce qui est très important
pour leur banc à l'issue d'une crise
comme celle que nous traversons
c'est la capacité du tissu économique et
donc du marché du travail localement
d'absorber le choc et de repartir vers
des activités qui sont plus profitables
ou plus porteuses d'avenir et donc ça ça
dépend évidemment essentiellement de
l'état du marché du travail localement
avant l'entrée dans la crise et de la
manière dont le colis tu vas va modifier
ou en tout cas va modifier les
perspectives des entreprises et donc des
salariés et donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment cette dimension là qui est au
coeur de notre analyse c'est à dire la
capacité d'absorption par le tissu
économique et donc par le marché du
travail local des difficultés engendrées
par la commune la deadline pour établir
ce plan tout cas identifiés les
territoires c'est le 31 mars nous avons
une première étape au 31 mars la mission
dure jusque jusqu'à l'été et nous allons
nous attacher dans les tout prochains
jours à établir une je dirais une série
de déplacements dans chacune des régions
de france qui cibleront
les territoires les zones qui cumulent
les difficultés les difficultés d'avant
et les difficultés de la crise
j'aimerais juste revenir sur un plan des
dons parler des aides tout à l'heure là
ça sort du cadre de votre mission mais
le 14 novembre dernier 200 maires ont
lancé un appel au président de la
république pour un soutien massif aux
quartiers populaires il déplorait que
les 1% du plan de relance qui était
prévu pour ces quartiers populaires
n'arrive pas et qui n'arrivent pas à
obtenir ces financements
le gouvernement a décidé de réunir fin
janvier un conseil interministériel des
villes
ce sera une première depuis l'élection
d' emmanuel macron c'est mère voulait
rencontrer et qu'elle remontait vous
avez sur le terrain et notamment dans le
département des yvelines je pense à
catherine arnould par exemple du côté de
chantoux qui fait partie et qui mène un
petit peu cette non pas cette fronde
mais en tout cas qui alerte sur cet
argent qu'ils n'arrivent pas et qui est
nécessaire aussi
oui absolument mais je crois que les
quartiers de la politique de la ville
sont comme d'autres territoires de la
république en je dirais en déclin et qui
convient de les soutenir
la crise de la coved aura sans doute eu
des conséquences pour ses quartiers je
pense notamment à tout ce qui concerne
les les indépendants parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'indépendants dans ces
quartiers et donc il faut que là où que
nous ayons une attention très
particulière et vérifier effectivement
que les mesures de soutien d'un côté et
que les dispositifs du plan de relance
de l'autre viennent bien répondre à
l'urgence dans ces quartiers là un
dernier mot jean-noël barrot j'aimerais
revenir avec vous sur la disparition
d'une figure de votre parti nous avons
l'occasion de vous faire réagir à ce
moment là c'était mi janvier la
disparition de marielle de sarnez décédé
à 69 ans présidente de la commission des
affaires à l'assemblée ancien ministre
des affaires européennes elle a aussi
été député européenne élue dans la
circonscription de l'île de france
c'était aussi une figure est avant tout
une figure du courant centriste alter
ego de françois bayrou
quelle image vous garder d'elle écoutez
notre peine collectivement est très
grande et aujourd'hui auront lieu
plusieurs hommages à l'assemblée
nationale et nos larmes ne sèche pas
mais
le très bel hommage qui lui a été rendu
hier par ses proches et et par la classe
politique française il est plus hautes
autorités de l'état
je crois nous ont élevés nos coeurs et
et nous inspire à suivre son exemple
c'est à dire une fidélité à l engagement
et une grande générosité aux autres elle
à façonner votre mouvement aussi le
centrisme le modem
qu'est-ce qui va perdurer aussi de son
action ben je crois que toute la famille
modem rassembler autour d'elle et de sa
mémoire depuis ces quelques jours et est
absolument habité par le l'exigence
absolue de préserver et de faire
fructifier son héritage et en matière de
politique son héritage c'est la
constitution d'un centre indépendant qui
a permis l'élection d' emmanuel macron
et qui nous convient de continuer à
structurer et à faire grandir
c'était aussi une européenne convaincue
là aussi c'est important de le rappeler
oui absolument c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui est dans l'adn de notre
mouvement et que nous allons continuer
de défendre inlassablement et pour être
à la hauteur de ce qu'elle a fait pour
pour l'europe pour la france et pour
notre mouvement
merci beaucoup jean noël barrot d'avoir
été avec nous députés chargés à présent
d'identifier les territoires fragiles
pour accompagner le rebond économique
mission confiée par le gouvernement
merci à vous nous quittons la politique
nationale nous revenons sur les enjeux
purement locaux avec le président de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
qui vient de dévoiler les grands axes de
sa mandature quel avenir pour les
territoires ruraux du sud du département
écoutait thomas gaulle
[Musique]
un projet de territoire c'est se
projeter c'est finalement se mettent
autour de la table les élus d'une
communauté d'agglomération comme la
nôtre pour réfléchir pour les dix ans à
venir
savoir ce que nous voulons faire où
voulons nous aller dire quel endroit
nous voulons porter nos habitants
finalement c'est définir l'avenir commun
a rassemblé émergence de la volonté
territoriales premièrement quoi faire de
notre cadre de vie
nous avons une situation assez
exceptionnelle envié par beaucoup quel
avenir nous donnons à cela est ce que
nous préservons est ce que nous faisons
muté c'est la première question
deuxième question c'est les ressources
les ressources de ce projet se son
développement économique
comment faisons-nous pour favoriser la
création de richesses et le financement
justement de ce fameux projet et enfin
et ça c'est très spécifique à la nôtre
sud yvelines
c'est le problème de mobilité le sujet
du déplacement des placements qui va
être quand même marqué par la nouvelle
donne que engendre maintenant cette
pandémie locaux vides et les nouveaux
usages et une nouvelle façon de
travailler de laison domicile travail
calendrier livraison avant l'été 2021
nous sommes en pleine phase de travail
en ce moment avec un rythme qui est tout
à fait soutenu nous nous réunissons tous
les mois à 67 conseillers communautaires
pour régler cette feuille de route et je
suis très très très optimiste sur le
fait que en juin prochain le serons en
mesure de vous présenter la feuille de
route pour les dix ans à venir
c'est la fin de ce set 8 politique on se
retrouve prochainement sur tv 78
l'actualité politique est aussi à suivre
au quotidien dans le journal de la
rédaction du lundi au vendredi à 18h à
très bientôt
[Musique]